théo général aujourd'hui il ya le fait
que tout le monde ait la parole ça
change tout au csa par exemple conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel on peut il ya
l'humour est complètement sanctuary zay
c'est à dire qu'on ne on était revient
pas le csa n'intervient pas lorsqu'il
s'agit du mois sauf si effectivement on
déroge à la loi
évidemment ça exception mais c'est
réservé il est intervenu sur tech qui
est interne à lucien barrière est
intervenu sur nous également donc bien
vous ne la voulez non mais un territoire
ça c'est la théorie
et là normalement le csa n'intervient
pas dès que c'est couvert de l'humour ça
c'est vraiment moi ça a été le cas alors
le regard de textes leucate billard mon
cas comme environnantes ou mondiale de
2009 en 2015 il ya une seule fois le csa
est intervenu sur le mot c'était
lorsqu'il y avait lorsque c'était sur le
rwanda
c'était vraiment quelqu'un de rigide sur
un génocide mais jamais mais alors après
we had an après et comment comment elle
a eu des amendes à l'orme à une loi mais
petit à petit justement il ya eu la
pression des réseaux sociaux
pourquoi mais j'ai dit ok donc chedjou
alors médias vous dire sur moi le sa
mohammadia la vérité vous je vais faire
une petite parenthèse sur le csa que si
on a pu tout problème d'ailleurs en plus
et qui s'est passé très bien maintenant
puisque le prêt l'ancien président est
parti il est allé faire des marrons
chauds si c'est pas c'est que c'est ça
c'est qu'il n'est pas du tout vu la
séquence ils ont même vu la séquence
mois nous sont pour laquelle on a pris
trois millions d'euros d'amendés et ils
ont rien dit et ils ont vu un
déferlement sur les réseaux sociaux de
plusieurs associations et de personnes
voilà qui ont fait monter la sauce après
pour se rendre compte en plus que tout
ça était fou et que tout ça a été monté
par une association
voilà est donc derrière qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est ça ils sont ils ont subi
une telle pression qu'ils sont dit il
faut qu'on intervienne ya même la
ministre marlène schiappa voilà donc que
voilà que je connais bien maintenant
qu'ils étaient intervenus et c'est vrai
que ils ont subi une pression mais en
fait il n'avait même pas vu l'extrait
l'extrait l'isae pas choquer et mine de
rien on s'est rendu compte après nous
dans notre affaire que tous avaient été
montées de toutes pièces
voilà mais le csah mélenchon
moore est près de moi jusqu'au chine
le mouvement s'était l'humour est une
affaire de contexte n'a faire d'époque
et par exemple effectivement ce que par
exemple
elie semoun on en rigole encore beaucoup
des blessés moon semoun la une un homme
aux traits noirs je peux me permettre
l'expression mais il ya déjà des
extraits d'elie semoun que les chaînes
elle-même censure à la télévision et
s'auto censure ne m'a pas la télé le
sketch avec moi moi j'ai dit moi j'ai
dit non parce que ça c'est mon avis
personnel je pense que l'union j'arrive
pas à comprendre tu dis que le csa
intervient pas moins à dire sur le cas
de laval et d'incinération et le cas de
theix
c'était un signalement de marlène
schiappa hausse et se rassurer dire pas
et donc l une sans jamais rien non je
t'ai dit qu'en théorie maintenant selon
l'index mais en prêt selon les seuls
noms mais christine n'était pas alors et
balotelli l'état le sessad n'intervient
pas sur l'humour et c'est complètement
s'en va on va les attaques et la barre
oui faut attaquer au conseil d'état mais
voilà les auris et surtout que ça ça
dénote d'un manque d'indépendance des
organismes d'autorité des organismes
régulateurs qui de même madonna c'est
une question aussi de la société change
dit pierre et les réseaux sociaux ils se
sentent investis d'une mission pour
faire une blague dans une ville on peut
pas faire la blague dans une ville
pourquoi est ce qu'on peut faire une
blague et ça personnellement pourquoi
j'ai dit non suivre cette voie
pourquoi pour moi l'humour ne peut pas
être véhicule facile pour des propos
déplacés
ça c'est mon avis il cherche alors à
déplacer des propos racistes des propos
homophobes la brague des propos mot la
blague de jean marie de gars qui étaient
ces qui était sexiste
vous vous l'auriez sanctionner ou c'est
ça qui a été la plaque de jean marc et
jean marie bigard qui l'avait fait sur
le pathos et en direct
derrière ça l'était n'était pas alors
que je pense que rayon un fait
furieusement bas en tout cas et je pense
que j'aurais mis dans la balance si
j'étais au csa à cette époque le fait
que sur rtl il a fait la même blague le
fait qu'à plusieurs reprises il a fait
la même blague et moi j'aurais
si j'aurais appelé la chaîne pour lui
dire faites attention éviter peut-être
mais ne sanctionnait pas voilà pourquoi
parce qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde a la
parole se réveille tous les vols et les
gens n'acceptent pas lorsque le sait ça
m'est arrivé à plusieurs reprises le csa
n'intervient pas sur un sujet mais on se
fait oui c'est ça on aimera classe et
aussi les procès sont prévues ces mahina
et je vous dis même des ménages il ya
plein de journalistes aussi qui dit que
fait le csa fait le set et je voulais
refaire deux fleurons à machin chouette
gars gagnent en un kiné on l'attend
louis vous savez combien de l'ati a eu
cesse encore moins de dix noms
intéressants à moins de dix plateaux 16
et pourtant ça peut choquer